[Music]
for nutrition it's for treating severe
acute malnutrition of children as things
stand this may end up being the last
shipment of humanitarian Aid food and
medicine from Turkey into Northwest
Syria
4.1 million people rely on this Lifeline
but it must be authorized by the un's
security Council
and in the council chamber there's
deadlock a resolution to allow the
crossing to operate for another 12
months was supported by all members
apart from China which abstained and
Russia which used its veto Russia then
presented its own rival resolution
allowing the crossing to operate for six
months but it didn't pass it was only
supported by Russia and China this is
not a moment to mince words I have long
said that this is a life and death issue
and tragically people will die because
of this vote
and the country who shamelessly deployed
The veto today
negotiations will continue the current
authorization for the border crossing
runs out at the end of Sunday but Russia
doesn't sound in the mood for compromise
if someone
proposes our draft we would not say that
this is our intellectual property if
someone proposes our draft for the
second time why not if not if not um I I
think that the page is over
so I asked the U.S ambassador with the
Russians unwilling to compromise will
she have to back down and accept the
Russian proposal now that would be very
humiliating for you but it would be
better than nothing wouldn't it his
resolution was nothing
we got 99 of the way there with the
Russians we gave them 99 they admitted
they got 99 and they were holding out
for one percent to continue to give
support to the Syrian regime obviously
tensions around the council table have
increased because of the ongoing war in
Ukraine but this is about more than
Security Council theater and drama it's
about millions of syrians their lives at
risk from starvation or lack of medical
treatment James Bay's Al Jazeera of the
United Nations